blockchain today is bringing
transformations across industries
the likes of which we have rarely seen
before one of the top technologies for
the future
it is helping companies evolve how they
conduct transactions
and business this is just the beginning
and organizations around the world are
looking for expert blockchain
professionals to integrate blockchain
into their operations and drive
exponential growth
simplylearn is proud to introduce its
new professional blockchain
certification training
in partnership with the indian institute
of technology kanpur
this program will help you jump start
your career with a cutting-edge
curriculum
designed by noted industry leaders and
one of india's finest academic
institutions
iit kanpur is one of the leading names
in the field of blockchain
developing best practices and techniques
that companies are looking to adopt
and with the perfect blend of master
classes from iit kanpur faculty
and our unique online bootcamp you can
learn all about concepts of bitcoin
hyperledger ethereum corda multi-chain
blockchain platforms
and hyperledger fabric to add to the
list
you needed to even leave home or your
job to learn all of it become a part of
a global cohort
with equally passionate professionals
driving your learning experience more
insightful
with eight times higher live interaction
via virtual classrooms
discover immersive and applied learning
to master top-in-demand tools
with four plus hands-on projects and
integrated labs
70 hours of applied learning and get the
only training you'll need to become a
blockchain expert within four months
it is finally your time to shine and the
way ahead is laid out for you
complete this two minute application
form and our consultant will walk you
through the prerequisites